I think that society always forces you
to smooth out your edges you know when
in fact those edges are probably going
to help you stand out or keep like when
I put that like when I shouldn't
[ __ ] ooh cheese office ah that's a
little too far I I wouldn't tell you
wouldn't do it no but I know can I just
say this though the real story is this
I'm gonna tell you the real story so the
other one was a fake story it wasn't
fake but it's you know some callused
know sometimes I tell stories and I take
things out of it just so that to make a
certain point so if I say yeah man I
[ __ ] and [ __ ] uchi my executive
producers office as a [ __ ] you know
me [ __ ] you yeah it sounds punk-rock
yeah so in is if I want to be punk rock
I just say it that way so it's like
sometimes the truth what's the reality a
reality is this very R&B very arm
breaking news here we go guys so i
Barinholtz he was on the Mindy project
he's also neighbors and other other
Suicide Squad
he also wrote that movie do you write
neighbors no he wrote that movie with
the rock and Kevin Hart Kevin Hart ah
yes central via him and David Stassen
wrote that movie Ike and Nicole Parker
were writing in [ __ ] suji's office
okay I walk in I go what you guys doing
they go we're writing a sketch and I go
oh cool I don't know what to do I got
nothing to do and they're like and I
just goes stick this in your [ __ ] and
he had great there was comes on dicks
desk right and he did as a joke so I go
okay I'll stick it on my [ __ ] so I
took three Tom's
I pulled my pants down I bent over and I
stuck three tongues into my butthole
okay then my buckles sort of frothing
don't put some in your butthole starts
frothing yeah but Tom's do when you're
in your butthole cuz of the is it
dissolving dissolving in my bunghole
yeah right so my butthole started fra
things and which created which created
immense amount of laughter from Ike and
Nicole which you like which is good
which is I like it number one
number two it's like they're laughing
number one because they didn't couldn't
believe that was doing that and number
two no one knew that that would happen
if you put it comes in a butthole
so you science yeah you're learning -
yeah so I stick it in my bunghole and
then I try to [ __ ] out the toms goddamn
and three of them shoot out but you're
like now half the size they once worked
but then what came out after that was a
bunch of [ __ ] so imagine tongues and
[ __ ] on the ground yeah now Nicole me
and Ike we're we're literally crying
laughing like it's the greatest thing
that's ever happened right then dick
masucci my executive producer of my show
walks in and he goes clean that up what
was - I hid in his room yeah but it
wasn't because of the fact I was saying
[ __ ] you to him I bet a bunch of people
not heard the original story are saying
[ __ ] you to their bosses and just taking
[ __ ] you know I have to say the the the
real real story is actually cute it's
funny yeah I know be repenting awhile
feel ya punk rock or not punk rock or
not yeah yeah yeah but that's the real
story about that but it's like I don't
you know what it is is I just when
someone says to do it and if I see a
laugh at the end of whatever the action
is I'll do it
yeah okay I have an important question
for you and if this is a real honest
inquiry because you seem all your
stories always involve sticking
something up your ass like all so you're
you have this anal fixation you have
this appeal you you you desire things in
your ass it's a moment I try to so much
as put a quarter of my pinky in there
cuz the freaks out that's not funny
there's no audience there number one
there's no audience number two it's not
funny and number three it doesn't feel
good - three points so you're saying if
I did it in front of a live audience
and they laughed at it you would do it
if I got my friend if I fisted your
[ __ ] no if I did this if I did this
if I at the end of my shows go hey guys
I went to a magic trick right
and my assistant kalila comes up on
stage right and I pull my pants down I
bend over right and I had already
in like maybe a plastic dove in my
butthole first of all that's a specific
know what just listen to the magic dress
figurine so I have I stuck a little
plastic even dove in my butthole yeah
and then my assistant sticks her finger
in my butthole and pulls out this
plastic Dobby but tada
I didn't that'd be funny I would do that
yeah so but other than that what you're
doing it for is sexualities I'm doing it
for power don't like it yeah I'm doing
it as like past a bold chest move I pass
on it he passes
yeah all right to myself but yeah
[Music]